high-low high-low left light opposite
directions pour from them understand the
balance of confidence and humility
understand that art and science
understand identities balances are
playing out in our society find your
balance
your extremes hold those opposite
feelings and try to make diamonds out of
the friction I spend so much time trying
to reconcile what I am on the field and
what I am off the field why why when I'm
on business you know why my when I'm in
business with my job yeah why when I'm
on stage why when I'm debated why when
I'm interviewed why when I'm gonna pitch
why why am I so fierce and hungry and
chiffon shoulder and win and not minute
applause win with don't respect the
[ __ ] moon but why off the field why
one-on-one do I hate confrontation do I
want to bring more value to the other
person that I want happiness and
positivity what looks like the opposite
is it necessarily but I try to
understand the differences they try to
understand and try to figure out the
balance of the feelings that came inside
of me when I'm often on the field and I
believe so many of you are so different
professionally than you are in your
regular life and the analogy that jumps
to me is 100% the sports analogies that
I understand the best which is how many
of you on the athletic field
different version of who you are off the
field that for me for me that's my truth
of how I play in business and how I
pecan even struggling fight when that
game fair the right way and how off the
field let me shake that competitors hand
that I wish them nothing but the best
I want to destroy the competitors in
business but boy in real life do I wish
nothing but help in happiness and all
good for them I want to win in that
context please please start trying to
understand the things that make you take
in your extreme differences that you
pull from other directions because in
there is the magic then there is the
happiness for the rest of your life try
to reconcile and create frameworks and
conversations and debates with yourself
to how you can pull in different
directions have different aspects of
your game be different in different
scenarios and reconcile them and make
them a clean complex understanding
concoction just need a great bottled
wine it's a blend you've got to find the
right balance of those five or six
grapes and that's what I'm trying to do
that's what I want for you
I don't know Papa the piston in the
midst of making my project I feel like I
am right now this is already the third
video I feel like I'm gonna have to bust
out another five or six it's a moment
for me a woman not clarity but I'm in
tune to where I am and what's happening
my ambitions and my realities I think
some feeling
so much good doesn't have to happen so
much good is about to happen
and it's looking at the bad you're
missing the opportunities to be a part
of it loud and aggressive positivity is
needed now more than ever in yang right
you can share your concerns
and odd in the negative aspects of the
Metro human climate right now
business-wise politics our science all
of it
please be in Reverse as well
and speak your positive cheats and see
all the incredible mists and understand
how much opportunity there is
find your balance standard left and
right the dark and light they're all
been enclosed your aggressive impassive
find your balance and communicate it